"Look upon each other"
"and say the words."
I would say the challenge with this
sequence was finding a way to present information that at least a good portion of the audience already had
in a way that was dramatic and exciting.
"The High Septon wed Rhaegar and Lyanna in a secret ceremony."
There's always meant to be a montage.
"Is this something you can see?"
The important thing was getting Sam and Bran together because they had
varying pieces of the puzzle, but they didn't have all the pieces.
"Cut." "Good." "Good."
"And so you see that actually these were two people in love and that this whole thing that started off"
"the series Game of Thrones, Robert's Rebellion was a total lie."
John is not just the son of Rhaegar and Lyanna
but he's the true born son. He's not a bastard.
And that means he's the rightful heir to the Iron Throne, that changes everything.
Man!
It's great to shoot something that's a revelatory moment and then of course the even bigger revelatory moment.
I think they both know it's wrong. I think they both know it's gonna cause problems, but it's that thing when you suddenly feel that
deeply about someone it's like a runaway train. You can't stop it happening.
You don't even get the relief of how beautiful it could be or should be. It's not good,
but it should be, but it's not.
And she's his aunt, so there's that if that kind of thing would bother you.
*fakes gagging* Might be the reaction.
I like looking at her and going "Oh god. I'm sorry. Let's, let's go again."
But the fact he is actually heir to the throne, I can lord that over Emilia every day. Every day. *laughs*
We tried to
contrast the various season endings so that they don't feel too similar. So last season we had a pretty triumphant ending with, um,
Dany finally sailing west towards Westeros. You're supposed to feel like, you know, like fuck yeah.
And this one's like oh...nn...fuck no. *laughs*
As a season closer it's phenomenal and from a directing point of view, okay? How do we do that?
Every year Dan and David have cooked up something that makes us read the outline and the script and just go "Holy
shit, how the hell are we gonna do this?"
And what really kind of got me super jazzed, I guess, was when we saw the first conceptual paintings.
They're not specific to shots or whatever,
they're just like "This is the vibe of this scene" and so they'll do this like beautiful
painting of a, of a dragon you know blowing blue flame, blowing a hole in the wall.
You're like "Now I see it. Holy crow. Like that is
spectacular!"
And a lot of it is virtual.
There are only so many pieces you can physically shoot.
Of course, whatever we can shoot we did shoot.
We have fire elements that were shot, that blast against the wall, wights on green-screen.
We have the Night King on a motion base on the back of zombie Viserion.
For the ice dragon we looked back at the models that we created.
When Tyrion visited the two sick dragons, their ribs are poking through the skin and their skin has become translucent.
We added the wound, which is very important, the spear wound that kills him. We also worked on what does his fire look like?
Because it's not healthy fire. It's, you know, it's a magical evil fire.
This sequence is a real proof of just
the dedication and commitment of that whole team of people working around the world to make something that's impossible and
unreal seem so real and so present.
"Run! Run! Run!"
I didn't see that coming. Now, like oh oh oh, this is gonna be fun.
Winter is here and it's all hitting the fan from all directions.
Yeah, we've talked a long time about seeing the wall come down. It's all getting real.
It's suddenly terrifying.
They're breaching the wall. You know, it's happening, and it's an amazing thing isn't it.
Hey everybody! Special Game of Thrones episode, so let's break it down.
They do a good job of explaining
some of the more contentious story points and what they intended. A lot of you have asked me about the conspiracy theories surrounding
the beginning of Robert's Rebellion and whether or not Robert found out about the lie and didn't tell anybody.
But they also clarify some of the mythology behind Viserion. So just a couple really big questions answered.
And if you didn't know, there's a brand new game of Thrones book that was just published this week.
It's a short story about the sons of Aegon the Conquerer. It even mentions one of Samwell Tarly's
ancestors called
Samwell the Savage. So that book is what the giveaway is going to be for this week. All you have to do to enter that
is be a subscriber, leave a comment on this video. Obviously
we're doing videos till season 8 gets here, but starting with the Rhaegar and Lyanna stuff.
So there weren't as many big questions about the "what", the "why" was the bigger thing here.
And I love the way that they say most of the audience understood.
But they still had to explain it in a visual way.
They said they had that problem all the way back in season 1, so this has always been a thing for Game of Thrones, is
that they have to find a way for the show to convey information even if it's common knowledge. So R plus L equals J
has been a thing since the first book came out. People wondered after Ned Stark had his dream. Was he dreaming about Lyanna
having a baby?
Maybe that baby is Jon Snow?
Martin was probably always going to reveal that information in Winds of Winter. The problem is, is that even if he did, and that book
had been published years ago, before we got to season 6,
the show still has to do a version of that. So if you're wondering why the show doesn't do more scenes like this,
it's just because they're not absolutely relevant for big information reveals.
The only reason the show did this now is because they wanted to create drama between Jon Snow and Daenerys. Like create some cracks in
the Alliance. Create a reason for them not to be together.
So if you're wondering why we haven't seen the Trident or other big Robert's Rebellion flashbacks,
it's just because those scenes aren't necessary for what's happening in present day. So anytime
there's some contextual moment that they need and it's a really big book moment
That's what they tend to go for. But as for future flashbacks,
Just because the previous trend the last couple of seasons has been Jon Snow specific flashbacks,
I think that will continue to be the case so if we get season eight Trident flashbacks or something else
I think they'll also continue to be about John Snow. But I feel like for the most part
they've answered all the questions they need to about his origins. He's the true born son of Rhaegar and Lyanna.
He has a stronger claim to the throne than Daenerys now. Like Kit Harington makes that joke.
"I can lord that over Emilia every day. " *laughs*
"Every day."
Moving into undead ice dragon territory. This actually confirms some of the things that I previously
thought. Like my initial take after the episode aired. People were wondering, "Why blue fire? Why does Viserion work this way, given
what happened to him before?" The whole explainer is that it is the Night King's magic. He's breathing magical fire.
He's flying by magic, whether you think it works, it doesn't work.
That's what they were going for. I think the idea now is is, is he's more
powerful than the other dragons. Because Drogon is still the largest, I know it's kind of hard to tell because they're all so large now,
but Drogon is still proportionately larger than Viserion and Rhaegal. But I think I added it to a previous video, Neil deGrasse Tyson
was going all science on the episode where he said that the blue fire was basically three times hotter than regular fire.
So even if you're not thinking about anything else with the Night King's magic, that by
itself would make Viserion more powerful than the other dragons. So the Night King has had a thousand years to perfect his magic. He gets
his hands on a dragon. He probably knows more about the dragons than Daenerys does and the other big thing, they don't quite clarify it here,
but the idea of whether or not
Viserion's blue fire can actually hurt Daenerys. The dragons are capable of killing each other,
so I think that Daenerys is only resistant to Viserion's blue fire.
But if she were to bathe in that, one, her clothes would all be incinerated
So she'd be naked after that. All of her hair would be singed off and she might get some third-degree burns,
but she could probably soak a little bit of damage and that's just going on the TV shows logic.
Daenerys in the books is a little bit different. The way the blood magic protects her against the fire.
But a lot of the way any of those battles go will depend on who's there to help them out because I don't think they're
gonna do any of that by themselves. But the whole deal with that new short story that George R. R. Martin
just published is that it's a sequel to the Princess and the Queen and the Rogue Prince. Dealing with
Targaryen kings after Aegon the conquerer. So the new one just deals with his two sons, It's actually pretty cool,
so I'll probably do a video on it in the next couple days and read a little bit from it.
It's only about 26 pages long, but it's always fun to read those stories, and see how Martin invokes a lot of the stuff
that's happening in present day. Like there are a lot of themes that recur.
There are a lot of people that have the same names like Samwell's
ancestor Samwell the Savage. So I know I also said I'd do a casting video for season 8.
There are a couple minor roles that they're casting, so that'll come in the next couple days too- but tonight at midnight
they're dropping a trailer for the New Mutants movie. Maisie Williams is actually in that. She's playing
Wolfsbane. So the "wolf" from Game of Thrones is playing a "wolf" in a Marvel movie. So that won't be till midnight tonight though.
Congratulations to "Dericforeal". Please private message me on the back
end of my channel so I can get your contact details. Click here to learn all about the season 8 episode
schedule. And you can click here for that Targaryen prequel trailer. Thank you so much for watching. Everybody stay awesome. I'll see you guys tonight.